[Musique]
cette semaine on a encore bombardé une
école en syrie si vous tapez syrie sur
google sur vos téléphones ou n'importe
où vous allez tomber sur une image que
je ne vous conseille pas de voir que des
images de destruction que des images de
morts que des images horribles moche
grise
je pense que personne d'entre nous on
aimerait qu'on parle de son pays et
qu'on parle d'une personne qu'ils aiment
de cette manière là surtout que pour moi
et pour tous les autres syriens la syrie
fut le lieu de notre construction et non
de notre destruction mois la syrie je la
connais je laime j'y suis né j'y ai
grandi je suis maire
c'est pas un exploit à manger rien fait
je suis né à l'epp précisément vous
entendez parler dahleb cette ville
détruite
et pourtant à lèvres pour moi si je
ferme les yeux je vais vous demander de
les fermer peut-être avec moi la
première chose qui me vient en tête
c'est une odeur magnifique une odeur de
brioches à la cannelle puis un goût de
glace à la cerise et à la pistache
il y avait sous chez mes grands parents
il y avait un endroit un boulanger et
son frère qui vendait de la glace
c'était juste devant et puis moi mon
enfance était passé d'une rue à l'autre
un bout de ça un bout de sein un bout de
sein un bout de ça c'était magnifique
et si je ferme les yeux et que je
grandis un petit peu plus
j'entends des bruits j'entends le son
des cloches des églises monde
avec le son des appels à la prière des
musulmans qui s'emmêlent les deux
ensemble et puis je vois des bigeon
voler dans le ciel faire des cercles
aussi eu vent d'un endroit à l'autre ils
vont sur le clocher
ils vont sur le minaret ils vont sur le
clocher ils vont sur le minaret et c'est
comme ça aussi la série ça a été pour
moi la découverte de la sexualité de
l'amour la beauté de cette découverte
l'un d'eux mon corps est aussi ça a été
les merveilles mans et la fierté
d'appartenance que j'ai ressenti la
première fois que je suis entré dans une
maison syrienne une maison
traditionnelle syrienne est ce que vous
connaissez les maisons traditionnelles
syrienne tout ce qu'on vous dit sur
l'accueil sur la douceur est résumé dans
ces maisons là on arrive souvent dans
les maisons traditionnelles syrienne en
marchant dans des petites rues il ya
rien autour de nous c'est des murs de
pierre puis on nous demande de baisser
la tête de rentrer dans une petite porte
l'âge vous voit mieux et de mende marché
dans un couloir
et là tout d'un coup on tombe sur le
paradis sur terre et c'est pas une
blague c'est une petit cocon de paradis
sur terre chaque maison a son propre
ciel avec ses propres étoiles chaque
maison à son bassin d'eau au centre avec
ses chats danser alkos et challans et
escaliers qui tourne parce que les
chambres sont en haut les salons sont en
bas et la cour intérieure à ses propres
arbres fruitiers ses abricots cédera ses
cerises et ses jasmins qui sont partout
sur les murs qui sont comme des étoiles
terrestre avec des odeurs de parfums les
poètes syrien 10 des maisons syrienne
que ce sont des femelles des matrices et
c'est comme ça qu'on les ressent et que
j'aille dans tous les pays du monde il
ya aucun pays qui pour moi est aussi
merveilleux que la syrie pas parce que
c'est le plus beau pays du monde mais
parce que c'est le pays où au moins j'ai
éprouvé mais premier émerveillement
c'est l'endroit où au moins j'ai
ressenti le goût de la vie alors que
j'étais enfin aujourd'hui il y à 5.5
millions d'enfants syriens touchés par
la guerre 5.5 millions de monde et
croulait des maisons syrienne détruites
des enfants qui ont vu des choses qu'ils
n'auraient jamais dû voir des blessés
des morts des parents détruit de
l'intérieur des à venir briser les
métiers écroulé des quartiers entiers en
cendres et puis des gens et des gens qui
quittent la série avec leurs enfants sur
leur dos avec des paquets qui partent
ils savent pas où ils vont ils savent
pas vers où ils vont mes parts et ces
enfants là ils suivent et souvent ils
sont une nuisance un peu parce que il
faut leur donner à manger il faut les
îles
il faut être là pour eux mais personne
n'est là pour eux le il suivit
comprennent pas et c'est horrible de
laisser les enfants devant cette
incompréhension je veux dire moi non
plus je comprends pas ils comprennent
pas non seulement ils vivent des deuils
et des douleurs et on va tous en vivre
dans la vie mais ce qu'ils comprennent
pas est la question à laquelle on ne
répond pas et que personne ne peut
répondre c'est pourquoi on détruit la
vie alors qu'elle est si belle
pourquoi on continue à faire la guerre
alors qu'elle nous fait si mal
je vous avoue que moi je suis sans voix
je ne sais pas quoi leur dire peut-être
il faut pas leur dire tentative pour
essayer de répondre à la question nous
mêmes en faisant en faisant la vie parce
que la grande victime de la guerre c'est
la vie elle même
c'est elle qui souffre et la guerre
n'est pas une raison pour qu'on aime
plus la vie au contraire la guerre est
la raison pour aimer encore plus la vie
et ça c'est des gens en syrie qui me
l'ont appris qu'ils nous l'apprennent
des gens dont vous n'entendez pas parlé
on entend le bruit des bombes on entend
le bruit du chaos on entend le bruit la
politique
on entend le vacarme horrible de tout ça
on entend les gens quittaient le pays
les histoires de réfugiés mais ce qu'on
entend parce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
qu'en syrie même il ya des jardiniers et
des couturiers et des couturières qui
sont tranquillement avec un fil et une
aiguille c'est des petites armes qui
sont ils sont en train de fermer la
terre là où elle a mal
ils sont en train de réparer la syrie là
où elle a man qu'est-ce qu'ils font
alors dans les zones assiégées
il y en a qui plante des jardins qui
créé des jardins et des potagers pour
faire des légumes à manger parce qu'on
ne trouve pas à manger dans les zones
assiégées dans les zones détruites
il y en a un qui décide de créer des
petites écoles qui invite ces enfants-là
du quartier qui leur font l'école à la
maison et qui centre qui sont ensemble
qui s'entraident
il y en a qui crée des cercles de
solidarité il ya des femmes dont une
amie à moi qui a tout quitté ici qui
retournait en syrie pour créer un
atelier de couture avec les femmes elles
sont toutes heureuses de créer des
petits objets qu'elles vendent pour
survivre il ya aussi ce papa à alep dans
un quartier détruit qui a décidé de
ramener autour de lui des enfants du
quartier et qu'ils avaient ensemble
peindre en bus de toutes les couleurs et
la plaie le bus de l'avenir est monté
dedans
et comme ça il avait traversé la guerre
est arrivée de l'autre côté heureux et
il ya ceux qui font jouer les enfants
aujourd'hui nous on a créé une fondation
qui s'appelle la fondation je veux jouer
on a décidé de mettre des faiseurs de
vie nous aussi à distance la fondation
je veux jouer veut pousser les enfants
de la guerre à aimer la vie de nouveaux
veut leur faire sentir le sentiment de
vie parce que vraiment en aimant de plus
en plus on veut créer une armée
d'amoureux de la vie c'est la meilleure
armée contre la guerre alors pourquoi le
jeu on nous fait souvent on se fait
souvent critiqués on se fait dire mais
ok le jeu peut attendre il ya d'autres
urgences franchement les enfants ont
besoin mais ton d'aller à l'école les
enfants ont besoin de manger de
s'habiller de bien sûr mais si je vous
dis pourquoi le jeu pour un enfant c'est
comme si je vous disais la vie peut
attendre
parce que le jeu c'est le travail des
enfants
c'est l'essence même d'êtres vivants
pour un enfant même les animaux jouent
c'est c'est le jeu le jeu c'est le
mouvement de la nature naturel pour
faire partie de la vie pour la prendre
pour l'éprouver j'ai un petit chaton
depuis quelques semaines lui il saute
partout ils essayent tout et grives tout
il tourne partout c'est vraiment sa
façon naturelle de connaître le monde
dans lequel il est de se connaître
lui-même et d'y trouver sa place jouer
en fait c'est et moi je travaille dans
le jeu c'est ce que je fais dans la vie
je crée des jeux pour enfants pour ça
que je crois dans le jeu jouer c'est
créer un espace avec certaines règles et
dans l'intérieur de cet espace où tu es
en sécurité tu es complètement libre
jouer c'est aussi poser une action et
avoir une réaction juste cette réaction
te donne un sentiment de vie et
d'accomplissement de john l'hymne pas
vraiment qu'on recherche
en plus jouer c'est jouer avec les
autres donc sacré des connexions ça te
refais sentir vivant ça reprend le
pouvoir à l'intérieur de toi sur la vie
quand je joue je suis profondément
vivant
on a même pu observer l'impact de notre
action
il ya un mois on a créé notre premier
espace de jeu dans le nord de la syrie
en dessous de la turquie dans un camp de
réfugiés qui s'appelle hotmail il ya 300
enfants qui vivent dans ce camp de
réfugiés avec leurs parents on a créé un
gros espace de jeux avec des ddd terrain
de soccer des terrains de basket ball
avec tout ce qu'il faut pour vraiment
jouer et être complètement dans une
bulle de jeu et d'enfance en une semaine
il ya eu trois mille enfants qui sont
venus de tous les environs de tous les
autres camps jouer dedans avec leurs
parents dans la vie en fait c'est un
appel à la vie on a pu constater que
même au milieu de la misère la du
désespoir appelle la vie elle fera des
miracles
moi je rêve qu'un jour partout en syrie
et partout dans le monde il ya des
appels à la vie comme des appels à la
prière comme des clochers d'église et on
verrait tous les vivants venir jouer
être heureux être ensemble parce que des
enfants de mon pays ne seront pas que
des survivants de la guerre ni que des
réfugiés
les enfants de mon pays parce qu'ils
auront vécu la guerre ils seront de
grands vivant et ça c'est la meilleure
claque qu'on peut donner à la guerre
merci
[Applaudissements]